[Music]
somebody saved me i think this is where
i draw the line we hate it this is the
cleanest this corner of the room has
ever been
stopped
oh my god it's chaos should i check the
room
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's the case
mom and i feel like i've lost control
look at my house it's very messy it's
usually very messy it is especially
messy and i think it's time for me to
have a little refresher as a mom and try
to improve as a parent because i'm
struggling right now so i'm going to
take a page out of some famous people's
books for an entire week i'm going to
try different celebrity parenting
techniques some of these are a little
unconventional but i'm willing to try
anything at this point so wish me luck
so matt is back in the office and that
means that i am home with the kids
during the day doing all of the school
child care cooking and cleaning while
trying to work my kids don't listen to
me very well anymore and something has
to change now a lot of these celebrity
parenting methods are criticized widely
but the point of this show is to be a
judgment-free zone we try everything
once as long as it's safe and we don't
judge other parents if their kids are
healthy and loved first up something
you've probably heard about recently
because it's all over the place is mila
kunis and ashton kutcher not bathing
their kids now to clarify they don't say
they don't bathe their kids at all
they've just said that they only bathe
them when they're very visibly dirty i
bathe my kids every day pretty much bath
time is part of our routine i have a
very lax daily routine but when it comes
to bath time that is a constant it is a
time that everybody is
pretty quiet for the most part people
are occupied i can sit and it's very
relaxing for everybody in my family so
i am nervous to give up that bath time
wyatt we all know is a spa king he loves
baths he loves luxurious
long drawn-out baths and so i think this
will be the hardest on him
you smell pretty bad
no you don't want him on your lap he has
a
diaper full of poo poo with henry in
particular i felt like i had to be a lot
more careful because he wears a diaper
so he does need regular bathing so the
no bathing is going great we've already
had one massive poop explosion hello
okay so one bath down the other boys on
the other hand are still going strong
not smelling too bad so we'll see how
long that goes you know we live in dirt
we live in a dirt patch like we are
dusty people our backyard is dirt every
day with the older kids i would have to
do a once-over of like how much dirt do
you have on your body grime test
jackson why is your head wet don't even
ask
why is it wet because we took a walk
and i wrote a scooter
look at these feet quiet let me feel
these crusty locks when things got
really gross like topically gross i did
find a loophole here's how we get around
the bath thing okay now if you want to
like scrub your hair out a little the
rest of the boys took one bath that week
henry took two total and
no never again so sorry mila and ashton
it may work for you it didn't work for
us i'm gonna label that parenting
technique not helpful for me next up is
the queen herself
madonna
she keeps her kids in check with the
laundry business which to me
is something that i've really struggled
with in my house my house is one giant
laundry pile at all times so i was
really excited to try what madonna does
madonna said that if she saw dirty
clothes on the floor of her daughter's
room she would take her clothes away and
her daughter would have to earn them
back by being tidy i had to tell the
boys i had to give them a heads up and
they did not react the way i expected so
if i see like laundry on the ground i'm
taking away all of your clothes
why
[Music]
okay
i'm not
joking i'm not joking how am i gonna
take rosie out of the restaurant naked
so throughout the week i would do
surprise room checks should i check the
room
to my surprise they actually stuck with
it and did a pretty good job this is the
cleanest this corner of the room has
ever been and i feel like i don't need
to take this away because they're
actually listening to me so madonna that
is a really great technique and it
worked very well for me and i really
appreciate you hello
hi so
here's one of the
more interesting parenting trends that i
found brad pitt and angelina jolie used
to do family sleep nights with all of
their children they had a giant bed that
they custom-made and then they pushed
couches up against it for all of their
kids
and parents and everyone slept in the
same bed together wow now co-sleeping is
very common but that's usually with just
one kid
sleeping with your whole family with all
the kids in the bed at once is something
i had not heard of i never co-slept with
my kids i know myself
i know
my family and i just didn't feel
comfortable when they were newborns
having them in the bed so in my mind i'm
thinking i'm angelina jolie i am one of
the most famous women in the world i go
to sleep with all of my children
surrounding me
i cuddle up and nestle into all of them
at night we all wake up refreshed
that much closer so much more bonded
so in love as a family and we go about
our day
as magical beings that is not what
happened
not even close we're going to cuddle
come on
stay like that
jackson he's escaping
oh my god oh henry
so
i think that jackson and white are going
to be really excited i don't think this
is going to work out very well with
henry
careful careful
[Music]
okay so it's off to a great start are
you guys gonna let me sleep okay
ow ow ow oh you're on my hair
you know what else i don't love
you guys are not super fresh plus the
boys were sticky because they weren't
bathing that week henry found a bat they
were trying to raid my nightstand
talkies
stop
stop oh my god
great good night everybody
good night no oh my
god so how much sleep did we get
really really honey i think i got about
two hours of pieced together sleep in
the end i feel like maybe this works
with the giant bed with the custom
sheets maybe i could pull it off but in
our current living situation
brad and angelina i'm sorry your
technique just doesn't work for me all
right so we've had a lot of conflict
these days a lot of yelling these days
since virtual school started so i'm
going to take a note out of will smith
and jada pinkett smith's book
they do not punish their kids they sit
down and have a conversation with them
about why they did what they did and all
the kid has to do is explain their
actions and then deal with the adult
consequences of it so i'm gonna try it
because i find myself just raising my
voice all the time and i feel like
nobody hears me and maybe it's my
approach so this whole technique is a
lot easier said than done i feel like
there were certain instances where this
really did work i heard you and your
brother fighting
you kicked him
because he
lacked a controller on my head so why
did you think that
why did you think that the thing to do
when someone hurts you is to hurt the
mat
so hard
what do you think that that was okay
yeah
i usually just get mad at jackson for
doing that but this time i had to sit
down with both of them and we all had a
conversation about
why when you hit someone they're
probably gonna hit you back in the real
world and you can't just go around being
physical and not expecting retaliation
but then also
understanding self-control
and not retaliating so it was a good
conversation for us to have together
instead of just doling out a punishment
and moving on here's the thing with this
technique it doesn't
always work because my kids are at an
age where the consequences of a lot of
their actions fall on me so it's a
school day virtual school day here's the
thing wyatt doesn't want to do his
classes so we're going to try the will
and jada method but here's the thing if
he gives me an explanation as to why he
get out of my makeup
if i give him the chance to explain why
and deal with the consequences of it
she doesn't really deal with the
consequences i do so in that instance
that technique doesn't work he has to do
school he doesn't have a choice he can't
explain his way out of it and he has to
listen to me have i seen a drastic
change no but i do think that they have
a better understanding of the
consequences of their actions and i do
think it's important to let kids
vocalize their feelings so will and jada
i really respect and admire
this parenting method and thank you i'm
eating a stale red vine it's very hard
he's begging me for a bite
mark her face
so i think it's time to do the one
parenting
that i've been dreading the most
alicia silverstone does
birding now the basics of birding
are
chewing your child's food and spitting
it into their mouth like a mama bird to
me it has always felt kind of gross but
i tried it with an open mind with no
judgment with henry
you're getting it out of mommy's mouth
here
ready
come here open your mouth
open your mouth
i tried this several times and he just
wasn't having it let me get you some
cheese
[Music]
all right there you go sorry i think if
he didn't know that there was an easier
way for him to just eat his own food
he'd be okay with it but he already
knows you know if i am holding my own
food i can eat it at my own pace and do
whatever i want and i don't want my mom
to be involved you know the one time it
worked is when i was chewing gum and he
wanted a lick of it and so i
figured we could categorize that as
burning
for a toddler
i think it's safe to say we hate it
maybe it works for somebody else we hate
it maybe he's too old we hate it i do
not ever want to do that again so alicia
silverstone i think it's very clear that
your son loved birding and i really
commend you for putting yourself out
there unfortunately birding didn't work
for us but i do really respect you so in
conclusion i feel like i learned a lot
from the techniques i tried i learned a
lot about what doesn't work for me but i
did take some good learning out of it i
really think i'm gonna use will and
jada's method of discipline in a lot of
different areas of our lives and also
madonna's laundry policy worked like a
charm some of the others just weren't
for us the lack of baths the birding
it just really wasn't something that fit
with our family but that's the beauty of
parenthood and raising kids is every kid
is different but it's a great lesson in
acceptance too so the next time we see
something published about a celebrity
parenting choice
it's just important to keep in mind that
they're people too and they're trying
their best too and there's no one right
way to be a parent even if you're famous
so that's it for now i'm hannah and what
did you think of these celebrity
parenting styles would you try any of
these is there anything i should
continue doing did you see anything that
worked because
i need some second opinions no if you'll
please excuse us i have everybody in the
bath
everybody's getting a big old bath
till next
bye
time
[Music]
you